what message does it send to Vladimir
Putin that the United States is not
fully implemented sanctions to counter
known Russian cyberattacks I believe
that President Putin has clearly come to
the conclusion there's little price to
play here bingo and that therefore I can
continue this activity yes I think in
fairness you can't say nothing's been
done but my point would be it hasn't
been enough I can't tell you that we
were looking at a number of different
things that we can do to prevent this
from happening and we're going to
continue to be tough on Russia moving
forward just as we have been in this
first year Admiral Rogers up on Capitol
Hill today talking about the Russia
interference in the election
interference that is continuing to this
day he said and a lot of back and forth
about what authority he's been given by
the President to address that with that
let's bring in our panel from our
Washington bureau Charles hurt opinion
editor for The Washington Times and Eli
Lake communists for Bloomberg view
joining me here at the White House marl
Eisen national political correspondent
of National Public Radio a couple of
eyebrow-raising moments in that hearing
today I thought there are a lot of
eyebrow-raising moments I think it's
incredible that the head of Cyber
Command is saying not enough is being
done and he hasn't been given the
authority to do what he needs to do to
counter Russian attempts to meddle in
the upcoming election we're not talking
about the last election anymore we're
talking about the 2018 election so
directly contradicting the White House
message which is we're doing plenty we
don't have to give him the authority
right he did say that he wanted to go
into closed session and tell you what he
was due right nothing that he said
they're not doing enough he loved well I
think it's important that specifically
Admiral Rogers was talking about
attacking some of these things at the
point of origin that's a pretty
significant cyber issue that is dividing
this administration and divided the last
administration originally this was
something that was proposed in 2015
under Obama and it didn't even get to
the President's desk because it was
considered so controversial in other
parts of the national security state so
at this point there are good faith
arguments for why you don't necessarily
want to escalate in cyberspace with the
Russians
until you know exactly how to respond to
this series of escalation
here's another exchange charlie with
senator Blumenthal I understand from you
that your feeling is you have not been
given authority to take additional
action that's correct sir have you asked
for that authority no I have not I've
tried to act within the authority that
has been granted in me to be aggressive
why have you not asked for additional
authority I'm not sure that the
capabilities that I have would be the
optimal or only response to this
wouldn't you agree that it is a
necessary response it could be a part of
a response I would certainly acknowledge
that I just think we need to step back
and look at this very broadly the bottom
line from this hearing charlie was that
it is continuing Russia is continuing to
try to interfere it has done it for
decades but it's doing it in an
aggressive manner in cyberspace now yeah
and it's obviously a very important
issue that I think that we've heard a
lot of Republicans who and we've heard
even Donald Trump talk about the need to
do something about it and they need to
combat it and how unfortunate was that
the previous administration failed to
combat it but I get a little bit worn
out listening to people like Blumenthal
you know talk about this in partisan
terms or Elizabeth Warren talk about
this in partisan terms you know part of
the problem with this entire thing is
the fact that it's been so utterly
politicized and it's not about Russia
per se or Vladimir Putin per se it's all
about Donald Trump and they're using the
investigation in order to punish a
political opponent and I think that that
is probably not the healthiest way to go
forward especially when you step back
and you look at what has been presented
so far from the Muller investigation and
that is no real evidence that there was
any collusion on the part of the Donald
Trump presidential campaign to collude
with the Russians to tilt the election
but that's not what we're talking about
now we're talking about protecting the
electoral system against future Russian
efforts to either meddle and voter
registration files to use sophisticated
propaganda there's all sorts of things
that this administration can do it has
nothing to do with Robert Murrow
collusion and that's great and I think
those are obviously things that we
should do and those are things that are
I think the Republicans have said that
they want to see done but my only simple
point is that when you start this by
politicizing all of it and making it all
using it as a cudgel to beat up Donald
Trump all day long it's it loses sort of
the bipartisan effect that we would like
in the meantime there is this security
clearance question here at the White
House and a decision was made last week
actually to take Jared Kushner from top
secret - secret clearance even as he's
dealing with big things like the Middle
East peace take a listen to the
president on Friday and Kelly and Conway
tonight you're chief of staff general
Kelley has recommended ending the
practice of granting interim security
clearances to members of the Trump
administration if that proceeds would
you be willing to grant a waiver to
Jared Kushner one of your senior
advisors so that'll be up to general
Kelley a general Kelley respects Jared a
lot and general Kelley will make that
call I won't make that call doesn't
Trump himself on Friday in front of the
whole world to see in his bilateral
press conference with the Australian
Prime Minister Brett that he has great
faith in Jared Kushner as his senior
adviser to continue to work on matters
affecting Middle East peace for example
the White House saying not about really
saying what exactly is going to happen
you lie down the road here there's this
Washington Post story suggesting that
there are some countries that tried to
use some financial disclosure issues
with Jared Kushner and other questions
to try to influence him your thoughts on
this story where it's heading and and
what what happens with it I think this
gets back to one of the greatest
vulnerabilities of the Trump White House
which is the failure of the President to
separate himself as the president fully
from the Trump Organization and all of
the potential conflicts and appearance
of conflicts that flow from those
decisions and I think that that's
something that's affecting Jared Kushner
right now I mean we don't know exactly
what the FBI has that has held up his
clearance but I'm willing to bet at this
point that it's because of Jared
Kushner's other career in real estate
and other things that have made him you
know entangled with other countries that
he's going to be having to deal with so
that's something that I think is going
to really be in the end probably more
damaging to this White House this issue
of separating the private business now
that they're in the White House from the
collusion stuff which you know at this
point we'll see what comes of it but
hasn't been proven yeah I mean we should
point out that it is possible that this
this clearance does come through whether
it takes a week or two weeks we don't
know what the holdup is or whether it's
not going to come through more or less
word on this about clearances well look
it's been almost a year Jared Kushner
has had to amend his security clearance
form many times in previous White
House's just having to amend it would
have been a reason to deny you the
clearance but right now he's been
downgraded to secret that means he can't
read the Daily Brief he can't have
access to highly classified information
he has a very broad portfolio Middle
East peace China Mexico it's unclear the
White has a lot of classified stuff in
there the White House says he can still
do his job but how can he do it as well
without this information we will see
okay